it is Milania prompts birthday I think
that's nice yeah today true story
president Trump tweeted happy birthday
to our first lady Melania
that was nice yeah yeah and this is
historic it's the first time Trump has
said something nice to an immigrant he's
just figuring that out now I did what
more controversial actions by President
Trump President Trump is considering
opening federal parkland to developers
yeah yeah in fact builders have already
broken ground on a Bed Bath and Grand
Canyon so you just like the idea of that
you're right you can see the Grand
Canyon and buy a loofa at the same time
ride a mule down to get some new sheets
yeah I'll do it
a new study came out says that the first
humans to arrive in what is now North
America may have been Neanderthals yeah
apparently they came here to vote in the
2016 election
terrible I kind of apologize there's a
crazy new device I don't have you heard
about this there's a new device being
sold by Amazon that helps users choose
what clothes to wear it's an Amazon
device that helps you choose what
clothes to wear yeah when you buy the
device amazon says customers who like
this may also like a gay best friend
looked like a gay best friend LA this
exciting la is one of the two finalists
to host the 2024 Olympics so if you want
to attend one of the events in LA you
should get on the freeway now wow these
are people that had trouble getting here
probably oh that's nice whoo traffic in
Philadelphia police are looking for a
man who robbed a Dunkin Donuts and was
caught on a surveillance camera doing
some stretches in the parking lot just
beforehand
doing stretches in the parking lot yeah
now police are on the lookout for the
only health-conscious person to ever
enter a Dunkin Donuts
I love that I just showed everybody
that's my stretch right there
you